The Joe Rogan Experience that we've been
gaslit in this conflict is like and it
just came out I don't know if you saw
this you probably did that zielinski
fired a bunch of his cabinet officials
over corruption and it was like they
were taking these fancy vacations to
Europe one of them was accused of
basically overcharging the military for
meals and remember I mean the amount
that we have sent to Ukraine and
propping up not only their military but
their government their economy Etc when
they're taking that money that's like
coming directly out of the U.S taxpayer
pocket and nobody reported on any of
this until zelenski fired people and
then it would then we were allowed to be
like yeah there's some problems with
corruption there maybe a little bit
maybe we should like worry a little bit
about where the weapons are going and
what exactly is happening before then
you weren't allowed to say it even
better the times actually changed his
headline they were like Ukraine uh goes
corruption drive and it was like
zelenski aims to Stamp Out corruption
just to make it a little bit less like
the appearance I have some fun numbers
for everybody this is from a past
monologue I've gone usaid currently at a
hundred billion dollars is double what
the entire rest of the world has given
to Ukraine in one year surpasses what we
gave the Afghan military in 20 years the
total amount to Ukraine now exceeds all
U.S military aid to the country of South
Vietnam between 1956 and 1975. wow a
hundred billion dollars
and listen I think what Russia did was
wrong I think it's an atrocity I think
the Ukrainian cause is just but the
total lack of debate the lack of
willingness to say like hey when we got
into this what you sold to the American
people is you're going to provide
defensive weapons only so Ukraine could
defend itself now we're sending tanks
now we're sending it just came out
longer range missiles that these were
things that were totally off the table
and then suddenly step by step by step
not only are they on the table but
you're not allowed to question it you're
not allowed to say hey guys are we
setting ourselves up for World War III
here which is something the president
himself was talking about not very long
ago and yet no debate and that's the
thing that you know however you feel
about the Ukraine conflict and you know
the build up to it and how we got here
and all of those things
I think at the very base level the total
lack of an ability to have dissent and
debate and understand the potential
consequences of what we're doing that is
[__] terrifying because we are
talking about a nuclear armed superpower
that we are engaged in a proxy war with
and you're basically not allowed to say
hey how does this end what do we need to
do to try to get to negotiated
settlement here how do we avoid having a
conflict with this nuclear armed
superpower World War III seems like a
bad thing to have on the table right now
and you guys are one of the few voices
of reason that will say that that agree
on both sides of the fence and this is
this is a thing that I there's a lot of
videos out now and I don't know if these
people get these videos but I get them I
get these videos of horrible War
encounters yes in in Russia and Ukraine
it's it's horrendous
and it brings me to this thing that a of
I think about a lot because I think
about things that other people do for a
living and their jobs and I think about
like they live in a world that I don't
understand you know there's like the CH
like I'm fascinated by professional
chess players they live in a world that
I don't understand because I don't play
chess I love the fact I kind of know how
the pieces move but I've really only
played like maybe 10 times my whole life
yeah I there's a thing that people have
it's a quality of being a human being
you only know what you know
and Other Things become like these sort
of like uh ethereal narratives they're
not necessarily real and war is one of
them yes war is one of them there's a
thing that people the way my friends who
served talk about war is so titanically
different than the way people who
ideologically support or disavow it like
you don't know what the [__] you're
talking about if you say there's no need
for a military you're crazy we are going
to get subjugated someone will come here
with men with guns if you take away all
the guns that everybody has no more
military we're [__] and if you don't
think that it's because if you'd never
gone to the the dark parts of the world
or you've never gone on telegram I'll
send you some videos I said I saw a guy
get killed with a hammer yesterday yeah
this is so important for people to
understand which is that we are 75 years
removed from what war on the European
continent actually looks like and you
know I've been on [__] Live Leak you
know since I was like 12
what are you watching I'm like what and
she's like a beheading or something my
wife would come into my office and I
have to pause videos and I'm like you
really want to see this
I can't handle it I can't handle it I
don't know I don't do I don't do well
with blood the point though is that you
know we have to try and convey this to
people and just say like hey when you're
on Twitter and you're like hey you know
[__] you you know anybody who's against
an interview like this is not a joke
like hundreds of thousands of Russians
are dead hundreds of thousands are
ukrainians are dead millions are
displaced we have no idea what the end
game is like and you know it's just what
Chris was saying I have this thing where
you know the fight club line like on a
long enough timeline I'm like on a long
enough timeline Ukraine is getting
everything that it wanted so originally
it was like no-fly zone and Biden was
like I'm being responsible I'm saying no
well first they ruled out Patriot
missile systems Patriot missile systems
are now on the way to Ukraine they ruled
out tanks now tanks are on the way to
Ukraine right now there's an article
talking about how f-16s there are
thinking about sending yeah the Pentagon
f-16s Biden says no now right exactly he
was saying no to tanks right like five
days before they send tanks he doesn't
remember that though yeah you're right
you gotta dig deep too like for example
originally we're like we just want
Ukraine to take back what it originally
lost and listen if I was Ukrainian I'd
be pushing for the same thing 100
sympathy they are not in the wrong here
they've been invaded by a foreign and
aggressive power that said like we got
to think about what's best for us right
now there's a New York Times article
about U.S warms to helping Ukraine take
back Crimea I'm like well hold on a
[__] second I'm not saying it's just
that Russia took Crimea in 2013 but they
formally annexed it and if you ask
people in Russia Crimea is Russia so if
they use if Ukraine uses a pentagon
provided F-16 to bomb Crimea now what
like now that's a violation of Russian
nuclear Doctrine they've updated their
nuclear Doctrine by the way to not even
say it's defensive they can say they can
use it in any capacity that Vladimir
Putin wants to that was a significant
change if you look in the history of the
way that the great superpowers actually
uh consider their own nuclear First
Strike use it's something that is
considered Ironclad and then boom it
changes like that you're not even going
to hear about this and I was heartened a
while back when there were some leaks
that came out of the Biden
Administration that he at like a donor
Event in San Francisco or something said
basically like we're you know we got to
make sure we avoid World War III I'm
paraphrasing but that was the he was
like we gotta avoid nuclear war we gotta
avoid World War III and I was like okay
good he's he's thinking about that
that caution that existed at that point
seems to be totally out of the window
and if you read you know the official
sort of like state state paper the New
York Times about the administration's
thinking they're like well you know
Russia said this nuclear stuff and it
didn't happen so they must just be
bluffing it must just not be real Jesus
and it's like okay number one was there
a timeline before they could press the
buttons oh they didn't blow up the whole
world yet so we should be fine I mean
that's insane number one and number two
the idea that Russia hasn't escalated in
response to our actions is just not true
they've been striking critical energy
infrastructure including you know in and
around Kiev which was an escalation they
went through with a conscription that
there you know was very politically
dicey for Putin there's rumors that they
may go through with another draft so the
idea that they just like took all of
this lying down didn't escalate is a
fantasy to start with but it's
incredibly dangerous and foolish to
think just because they didn't push the
nuclear button yet that oh it's all fine
and he's just full of it thank God
there's people like you guys out there
because there's so many people that they
have Ukraine in the same category of
importance and significance as they do
climate change
climate change which is a real thing but
it's it's a politically divisive
Alleyway where you're not allowed to
Veer from the course and even look at
any kind of science it's the same thing
with Ukraine a support from you for
Ukraine is undeniable you must put it in
your Twitter bio and you guys are saying
you're not saying don't support Ukraine
but you're saying look where this is
going do you understand what this is
because you can't just openly support
something you don't understand without a
comprehensive view of what the [__] the
factors are and how it got to be that
way in the first place and you're not
going to hear that in a five minute clip
on mainstream news you're just not going
to it's so important for and us to
internalize that message we're not
saying we don't we hate Ukraine we're
not saying we don't even support Ukraine
Ukrainian cause it's just we're saying
is what about our interests there are
interests that sub supersede Ukraine if
I was Ukrainian I would do exactly what
they were doing but guess what Ukraine
does not exist without the United States
we provide the vast majority of the
military uh there for the diplomacy
perspective if we cut off military
weapons to them tomorrow that's it done
they literally are forced to the
negotiating table I'm not even saying we
should do that I'm saying what is the
end game and you know in my neighborhood
there's more Ukraine Flags than there
are American flags it's like Ukraine
flag gay pride flag no American flag but
then it's like okay uh if you go to
those people and if it would just say
what they said they're saying this is
disgusting this is Russian propaganda
it's up to the ukrainians for when they
want to stop and I said yeah I
completely agree but it's also up to us
for whatever we stop providing them
weapons we're like hey if you want to
defend this part of your territory
that's totally fine that's our end game
my end game is not having a nuclear
conflict is making sure that we have
peace on the European continent Vladimir
Putin is an up opposition to that piece
but Putin and Russia are going to exist
you know something I think people should
take home too is you had Peter Zion on
he said it really well which is the
first year of every Russian conflict is
a total [__] show if you look at Finland
if you look at the first year of
Hitler's Invasion even going all the way
back to Napoleon and some of the czar's
campaign before that they lose a [__]
ton of people looks like a complete mess
they fire a bunch of generals all of
this and then what do they do they use
their vast Rush the Russian Colossus is
known of that for a reason because they
have a shitload of people they allowed
to have military materiel and they amass
it and they throw it at them and so
people are like you know soccer Crystal
like what you guys are saying will be
valid but Ukraine is winning look we are
barely a year into this one year into
the first World War I could make the
easy case that Germany was going to win
the first world war Second World War I
could easily make the case the Nazis
were going to win if I go back to World
War uh Civil War I could easily make a
case the Confederates were going to win
all three of those it didn't happen why
because these things go on for a long
time like you have no idea what it is
and one of the reasons that many of
those conflicts first and two went on
and uh ultimately came to the conclusion
they were was because a lot millions of
lives were lost and the whole point from
those conflicts if you look at the way
that people talked was we have to learn
the lesson we have to learn the lesson
but it's been 75 years and now this is
all game this is a tweet that people are
saying about Ukraine but it says real
world consequences for people that's it
that's it exactly and the the total lack
of an ability to have a reason to bait
without just being like smeared as a
propaganda yeah
don't read the comments it is a
terrifying moment
um and you know there's a couple things
that do uh give me some heart which is
number one even though like I can't
really blame the people who are just who
can't understand seeing it another way
because the propaganda that is coming
from every Network really like almost
across the board is very strong and it's
very hard to avoid that so I have
sympathy for that perspective but even
so uh poll just came out that had from
NBC news they buried this at the very
end of their write-up of the poll Publix
now 50 50 split on continuing Aid to
Ukraine so people are questioning even
though they're being fed so much
propaganda I think that is a credit to
the rise of Independent Media I think
it's also a credit to the fact
but because of Independent Media the
trust is informed or the lack of trust
rather right it's not just it's not just
knee jerk I hope I mean that's my hope
looking at those numbers yeah I think
your hope is 100 correct I think you're
right I think you guys are very
important Glenn Greenwald very important
Jimmy Dore very important Kyle Kolinski
very important people who are real
people that that actually have done the
homework and are going over the details
and can inform people because there's so
many people out there like I talked to
Dave Smith about the history of the
conflict between Russia and Ukraine I
was like what and he informed me about
the coup in 2014. oh my God a lot of
backstory and then we played the video
on The Colbert Show Bear show which is
just [__] Gideon something the guy
from The Times where he was like a book
he's selling a book in the book He's
comparing Russia and Ukraine to Batman
and Robin and he's like Ukraine is Robin
and we want to take robin and bring him
over to our side
and it's like this Open Secret they're
just openly you know there were um
cables from that actually Wikileaks
released and a friend who's a great
journalist Bronco Marsa teach who's been
looking at the Ukraine conflict with a
critical eye
um he sorted through these cables and he
found all of these diplomatic cables
from the prior era where you had um NATO
allies you had U.S officials who were
all saying hey guys Russia has red lines
here with regard to Ukraine and floating
NATO membership with Ukraine is a real
violation of their hard red lines and
we're very fearful and they laid out
exactly the trajectory that we could
find ourselves on now that doesn't deny
Russia agency or you know Putin in the
Kremlin Agency for invading no one made
them do that however it is to say that
you know there was a time when you were
allowed to acknowledge that you US
policy could lead to this exact event
and now when you even suggest that us
you know floating NATO membership with
Ukraine and saying that they were going
to be made a part that some of these
things were exacerbating they crossed
the red line and you know created a
situation that was incredibly tense
where this is the predictable outcome
again that's you're not allowed to talk
about that